Okay, in this lesson,
we're going to dive into how do we fill
a dataframe with the data that we want.
And we're also going
to touch upon a couple
issue that we had that were pointed
out in the previous lesson.
For instance, remember when we had that
issue that the dates were actually in
the reverse order when we loaded
them in, we're going to fix that.
We're going to fix
a couple other things too.
Okay, just to refresh your memory,
here's the kind of stuff that goes in
a dataframe, our columns are the
particular symbols of stocks that we're
interested in, and our rows are dates.
So time, goes from the top of
the dataframe down to the bottom, and
symbols, from left to right.